[Alkış]
bundan yaklaşık bir buç yıl önceydi Bir
gün % 70 indirimdeki bir ev tekstili
mağazasında kendimi havluların
perdelerin çarşafların arasında
debelenirken
yakaladım debelenmek de ne derseniz
indirimdeki bir mağazaya girip içerideki
insanlara bir bakın derim Ama o insanlar
bunun farkında değildir Ben o gün
içerideki bir insan olarak kendimi fark
ettim ve dedim ki kendime Şu anda ben ne
yapıyorum bu elimdekiler neden satın
alıyorum Gerçekten büyük bir indirim
vardı ama benim yeni Bir havluya yeni
bir hasta daha ihtiyacım
yoktu oradan bir iç sıkıntısıyla çıktım
Tabii bir de aldığım eşyalar Onları
bırakmamıştı böyle sıkıca
sarılmıştım Plazalar dolu büyük bir
cadde üzerindeki bir alışveriş
merkezindeyim o gün bu benim bulunduğum
Alışveriş Merkezi bana her zamankinden
daha kalabalık daha boğucu daha
gürültülü daha yapay geldi ve bir an
önce oradan uzaklaşmak istedim Aslında
uzaklaşmak istediğim Ne o mekan ne de
oradaki
insanlardı kendimdeki ve toplumdaki
tüketim
ruhuyum Ben Duyguların düşüncelerin
davranışların insandan insana yayılarak
topluluklarda bir ruh yarattığına
inanıyorum e hoşgörü gibi paylaşım gibi
korku gibi tüketimde böyle toplumda
yayılmış bir ruh hali ve e o kadar
içimize işlemiş ki artık
bir yaşam tarzı haline gelmiş bizim
için o yaşam tarzının kaleleri de Adı
üzerinde alışveriş
merkezleri şimdi yeni Şehircilik
anlayışımızda Yani şöyle bir şehirde
alışveriş merkezleri kendilerini
alışverişin ötesinde bir eğlence alanı
sosyalleşme alanı vakit geçirme alanı
yemek yeme alanı Yani tam bir yaşam
alanı olarak sunuyorlar bizlere zaten
böyle bir yerde yaşarken de başka bir
şansımız yok gibi
geliyor İstanbul'da bazı caddelerde 45
tane alışveriş merkezi var aynı cadde
üzerinde ama bunların hepsi neredeyse
birbirinin aynısı içlerinde aynı
uluslararası mağaza zincirleri var
alışveriş merkezine değil de şehrin
büyük bir caddesine giderseniz oraki
yer mağaza zincirlerin aldığını
görebilirsiniz ev hayatımı gelirsek yine
şöyle bir yerde yaşarken istersek
gökdelenlerde yaşayalım ya da toplu
konutlarda birçoğumuz Eve gider gitmez
televizyonu açıyoruz ve gece yatana
kadar dizi izliyoruz dizilerde muhteşem
Hayatlar var Herkes çok güzel Herkes çok
başarılı Herkes çok
zenginiz bu haylar
özeniyoruz ş en kolay yolu da orada
gördüğümüz bir kolyeyi geceliği
nevresimi satın
almak bunu bir pazarlama yöntemine
çevirmenin yolunu da bu işin uzmanları
yani reklamcılar çok iyi
biliyorlar reklamcılar bizim bütün
zaaflarımızı çok iyi biliyorlar ve onlar
için o zaafları kullanmak duygu sömürüsü
yapmak cinsel ve cinsiyetçi göndermeler
yapmak Gerçek olmayacak vaatlerde
bulunmak hiçbiri sorun değil Yeter ki
ürün satılsın o 1015 dakikalık reklam
aralarında kendimizi kah yaşlı bir
dedeyle bayramda torunumuz Beklerken
buluyoruz kah seksi bir kadına dondurma
yalarken buluyoruz yani duygudan duyguya
atılıyor Televizyon izlemeyi de
reklamlardan e kaçmak mümkün değil
reklamlar hayatımızın her alanında ve
bunun için hiçbir fırsat
kaçırılmış Özellikle de özel
günler özel günler artık bir Alışveriş
Festivali haline
geldi Sevgililer Günü Anneler Günü Zaten
yıllardır bombardıman altındayız Ama
artık düğünler doğumlar doğum günleri
farklı bir hal aldı Sadece o günün
mutluluğunu yaşamak yetmiyor
bize hepsinin bir konsepti var ve o
konsepte uygun ürünler
var bu arada moda var trendler
var sporak odası var işte eee müzikle
ilgileniyorsa hangi müzik tiri
dinlediğimiz göre ayrı teknolojiye
ilgili isek ayrı Hatta trendlere
karşıyak bile onu bile bir Trend haline
getirip bize satıyorlar
Eee Tabii bunları alacak Paramız Yoksa
da e bankalar kredi kartları veriyor ve
böylece olmayan paramızı
harcayabilir birçoğunuz bunun
farkındasınızdır
biliyorsunuzdur Ben de bunun
farkındaydım Ben de biliyordum ama
hiçbir şey değişmeyecek umutsuzluğu la
tüketim dünyasına katkıda bulunmaya
devam
ediyordu bizim toplumumuzda başka bir
ruh hali de umutsuzluk son günlerde daha
da artan bir şekilde olana razı olmak
başka şansımız yok diye
düşünmek bir birey tek başına Neyi
değiştirebilir ki Ama birçok birey hep
beraber birçok şeyi
değiştirebilir aslında şu anda biz de
hep beraber bir şeyleri değiştiriyoruz
ama bunu olumlu anlamda söylemiyorum
olumsuz anlamda söylüyorum hep beraber
dünyayı tüketiyoruz ve tükettiğimiz her
an kendi bindiğimiz dalı kesiyoruz çünkü
bunlar sonsuz bir kaynaktan
gelmiyor son 202 yıldır Belki de bizden
önceki nesillerin tükettiğinden çok daha
fazla şey tükettik bu bu katlanarak
hızlanarak
büyüyor son bir yılda tükettiğiniz
eşyaları düşünün satın aldıklarınızı
düşünün ne kadar bir alanı doldurur bir
kutu mu bir oda mı hepimizin aldıklarını
düşünsek bu salondakilerin bu
şehirdekiler
dünyadaki
insanların hepsinin bir yıl içinde
aldıklarını düşünün ne kadar bir alanı
doldurur Bu ürünler üretilirken hangi
kaynaklar kullanılıyor
e nasıl bir enerji kullanılıyor hangi
enerji kullanılıyor bu enerjiyi üretmek
için dünyanın Bedel nedir Bir taraftan
tüketirken bir taraftan heslere nükleer
santrallere Eee madenlere karşı olmak ne
kadar
samimi bir de bunları üreten insanlar
var bu insanlar hangi koşullarda
çalışıyorlar ne kadar emek harcıyorlar
bu emeklerin karşılığını alıyorlar mı
Belki Çin'de Vietnam'da çalışan Tekstil
işçilerinin çalışma koşullarına dair
Haberlere denk
gelmişsiniz ve bizim 10 liraya aldığımız
bir tişört
y doğal olarak çok eski elimizden çık ya
da modası geçiyor bunlar atıkları nereye
gidiyor dünyada bazı atıklar yüzlerce
yıl kalıyor ve bir yıl içinde çıkardı
atıkları düşünün şimdi ne kadar bir
alanı
dold gördüğünüz atıklar metrelerce
yükseklikte ve çok geniş bir
alana emeklerini kullanarak üretilen bir
tişörtü alıp 5 kere giyip onu sonra çöpe
atıyoruz dünyaya geri
veriyoruz e söylediğim gibi Bu bir
taraftan da şu var biz bunları almak
için kendimizden ne
veriyoruz yaşamak için birazcık da
hayatımıza tat katmak için ne kadar
eşyaya ihtiyacımız var Biz daha
fazlasını almak için ne yapıyoruz ne
kadar
çalışıyoruz yani hayatımız bu mu
çalışmak para kazanmak alışveriş yapmak
ve tekrar
çalışmak söylediğim gibi ben ben de
bunları biliyordum ama alışveriş
yaparken hepsini unutuyordum sanki
aldığım şey bir eşyanın ötesinde beni
mutlu edecek bir şey diye düşünüyordum
bir hevesle alıyordum sonra birkaç gün
sonra birkaç saat sonra pişman oluyordum
ald mutsuz
oluyordu bu bir psikoljik
TM doldurmak ya da bir sahip olma
isteği İşte o gün o alışveriş
merkezinden çıkarken artık bu döngüden
çıkmak için kendi adıma bir şey yapmam
gerektiğine karar verdim ama nereden
başlayacağımı bilmiyordum
Eee sonra ne yaptım acaba sonra hiçbir
şey yapamadım tabi nereden başlayacağımı
bilmediğim için ofiste birkaç gün
sonra
Yani bu konular üzerine düşünürken
aklıma daha önceden okuduğum Bir Haber
Geldi Bir yıl boyunca hiçbir şey satın
almayan iki Kanadalı ev arkadaşının
hikayesi haberi bulup tekrar okudum bu
iki insan bana değişimi dışarıdan
beklemem kendimden başlamam için bir yol
öneriyordu
dünya değişmeye bilirdi ama ben kendi
hayatımı
değiştirebilirim onaylamadığım bir şeye
katı
yaşayabilir Ben de o anda çok da
düşünmeden o saniyede bir yıl boyunca
hiçbir şey almamaya karar verdim ve
hemen bu kararımı da Facebook'a yazdım
ki vazgeçeyim diye Facebook'a yazar
yazmaz işte beğeniler yorumlar gelmeye
başladı Hatta süreci paylaşmamı da
isteyenler oldu bu da beni daha da
motive etti ve bir almadım isminde bir
Facebook sayfası ve bir blog
açtım Eee bu hem Böylece kendim motive
olurum hem de belki beni takip edenler
benim başkalarından etkilendiğim gibi
benim sürecim etkilenebilir diye
düşündüm o sıradaki Facebook Fotoğrafımı
da e bir arkadaşım Şu hale getirince bu
çocukluk fotoğrafım da artık benim için
bu bir büyük yemin olmuş oldu
Eee hemen bir O hevesle eve gittim
elimde ne var ne yok bir gözden geçirdim
Eee İhtiyaçlarımı belirledim ve bir
yıllık stok yaptım
Tabii ki öyle bir şey yapmadım yani Bir
yıllık stok yapsam zaten yaptığım Şeyin
Anlamı
olmazdı elimde ne varsa o sırada onunla
idare etmeye karar
verdim Bu benim hiçbir şey değişmiyor
umutsuzluğumu bir Umuda
çevirmişti ve böylece bu sürece
başladım kararımı Bir yıl boyunca
uygulamaya çalıştım ve yaşadıklarımı da
yazdım o blo
yaım içinde
öğrendiklerimi Almak isteyip de
almadıkları almayınca hiçbir şeyden
mahrum kalmadığımı bu sürece başlama
nedenlerimi yani size anlattığım şeyleri
ve kendimdeki değişimi
yazdım gerçekten o kadar çok şey varmış
ki ihtiyacım olmadan satın aldığım ya da
gereğinden fazla kullandığım E bir Diş
macununu mercimek tanesi kadar
kullandığımızda meğer bir tük neredeyse
bir yıl idare edebiliyormuyuz
benim saç kremine
yumuşatıcıya sıvı el sabununa ve birçok
şeye ihtiyacım yokmuş gereksiz yere
kullanıyormuş bu süreçte bir şeyi eskit
kadar
kullanmanın tamir ettirmenin kendimi
onarmanın bir şeyleri
üretmenin paylaşmanın değerini
[Müzik]
anladım evime daha az kimyasal ürün
girdi daha temiz sağlıklı gıda
tükettim bu
bir alşe harcayacağım zamanı ve parayı
da kendimi geliştirmeye yeni şeyler
öğrenme yeni yerler görmeye harcadım bir
enstrüman kullanmayı öğrendim ailemi
daha çok ziyaret ettim ve böylece bir
yılı çok da zorlanmadan
Bitirdim Bu arada arkadaşlarımla takas
pazarları yaptık ihtiyaçlarımızı
birbirimizden
karşıladık ün aldığım kıyafetlerle
kardeşimin nişanı ve düğün
atl Ç zorlanmadan bir yılı bitirdim bir
yılı bitirdiğimde toplam 5 tane ürün
almıştım
onlardan 3 tanesi
zorunlu tanesi Pardon bir tanesi
yanlışlıkla o sabun Bir tane de keyfi O
da bu bileklik kolumdaki bileklik bu
bileklik benim keyfi aldığım bir yıl
içinde tek şey olduğu için Benim için
değerli bir şey
oldu bir yı
bğ % indirimdeki mağazanın hep % 70
indirimde olduğunu öğrendim Eee Ama
debelenmek boşa gitmemişti bir yıl
bittiğinde benimle bir röportaj yapıldı
sosyal medyada yayınlandı ve e büyük bir
ilgi gördü açıkçası ilk bir haftası
Benim için zor geçti Çünkü tüketecek bir
şey sunmuştum ortaya O da tüketmemek E
işte benimle röportaj yapmak isteyenler
beni haber yapanlar oldu hatta bir Sabah
Magazin programında Beni Böle ü kişinin
arkasında benim fotoğrafımla saçı boyama
deodorant kullanıyor mu diye
konuştukları oldu
Eee diğer beni marka ve pazarlama
konferanslarına Davet ettiler Hatta
orada konuşmacı olarak yani biraz dikkat
etmezseniz sizi o tüketim dünyasının
içine çekebiliyorlar Diğer tarafta da
benim tüketmek için yeterince ekolojist
yeterince alternatif biri olmadığımı
işte zengin olduğumu halkın durumu
anlamadığımı Hatta ünlü olmak istediğimi
bile söyleyenler oldu Neyse ki bu Furya
çok çabuk bitti Bir iki hafta içinde
tüken endi geriye beni örnek aldığını
söyleyen sürecimi
Eee satın almamaya karar veren Kendine
zaman kısıtlaması koyan bunları
yollayalım
Eee tebrik eden teşekkür eden yüzlerce
mesaj yorum mail aldım Aslında ne kadar
çokmuş Biz y tüket ama tüketim dünyasına
katkıda bulunmaya devam ediyoruz E biz
aslında bizi bu sisteme sıkıştıran
lardan çok dah ama o umutsuzlukla buna
hizmet ediyoruz bir mucize bekliy o
mucize hiçbir zaman dışarıdan gelmiyor
Bizim kendi hayatımızı değiştirerek
başlamamız
gerekiyor Ben bu
süreçte kendinden başlamanın örnek
olmanın ve onu paylaşmanın değerini de
gördüm hem ben birilerini örnek alarak
bu sürece başlamıştım hem de benden
örnek alarak böyle süreçlere başlayanlar
oldu her olsun Biz kendi hayatımızın
sorumluluğunu aldığımızda Eee
düşündüklerimiz de yaptıklarımız bir
olduğunda
çelişmiş biliyoruz Ve bu samimiyet de
yayılan bir şey el birliğiyle dünyaya
tüketeceğimiz Samimiyeti ve umudu
yaydığımız bir gelecek diliyorum
teşekkür
[Müzik]
ederim
y